and you're going to have to dispel this
because bottled water we all bought into
it it's also the biggest con in first
world history
why why are we paying for it you know
what's a bigger con in first of all to
kill you
you want a better you want a better con
than first world in the world say
jews
okay jesus christ okay jesus gary let's
go let's go let's go let's go with
fashion
yep yes
yeah yeah i'm gonna hurt your feelings
you call both of them [ __ ] you
gotta call me ready yeah yeah fashion
yeah
one big game of the need to communicate
to others through what you buy yes
is why nfts but i love what you just uh
can i say this the number one yes you
can but i've got to get this yeah
the number one reason i'm positive that
nfts are going to win is because it's
fashion at scale
i believe which was the same reason i
knew that social was gonna win because
it was fashion at scale who got [ __ ]
off of nft so far
ungodly amounts of people who
i can't blow up people's spots like
you really think girls are [ __ ] you
because you got a monkey picture yes
there's no way no it's when you make
money off the monkey picture by the
house of miami that's money you think
girls are [ __ ] people because they're
funny on stage no definitely not but
they are it never happens have you ever
seen her
do you have you looked at adam sandler's
face
my intuition is adam funny on stage gave
him more leverage to pull than you not
funny on stage and you guys have the
same face thoughts
thoughts
yes being funny is better being funny is
better no no having leverage is better
yes not being funny being funny lots of
people are funny yes do they cross over
to the ability to have leverage with
that humor once they cross over to
having leverage then things start to
change at some point having a board ape
yacht club a year ago meant nothing
somewhere by the fall and winter of last
year it started to mean a little
something and yes i do believe that
people are hooked up because they've
owned a board api club i know it to be
true wow a girl dm'd oh my god nice
boarding no it becomes what a loser it
just signifies you're rich
in the same way what's the difference
between oh nice lambo or oh nice rolex
like a girl doesn't appreciate [ __ ]
the difference you can ride around the
lambo you can pick them up in the lambo
more people see that you have a board
ape than see you riding a lambo but you
don't need to follow more people you
just need to [ __ ] the one girl no no no
no don't don't try to like
you don't want to [ __ ] 73 people instead
of one that's disgusting dude yeah okay
that's [ __ ] disgusting i've seen this
[ __ ]
very happy guys that clip is brought to
you by bluechew the makers of hard dicks
and happy wives that's right your girl
deserves it even your side chick
deserves your best and the way you're
gonna deliver it to her is getting on
that chew same active ingredients it's
inside cialis or viagra but this is the
chew this is the one we rock with and
this is the one that we do spinal damage
to the ones we love with
make sure
you get your first month free by going
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code andrew you just
gotta pay five dollar shipping that's it
thank you so much for watching the clips
keep supporting the podcast we'll see
you soon
you